well you've uh
on the topic of concurrency you've
written the swift concurrency manifest i
think it's
it's kind of interesting anything that
uh has the word manifesto in is very
interesting
uh can you summarize the key ideas of
each of the five parts you've written
about so what is a manifesto
yes how about we start there so
in the swift community we have this
problem which is on the one hand you
want to have
relatively small proposals that you can
kind of fit in your head you can
understand the details at a very
fine-grained level
that move the world forward but then you
also have these big arcs
okay and often when you're working on
something that is a big arc
but you're tackling in small pieces you
have this question of how do i know i'm
not doing a random walk
where are we going like how does this
add up furthermore when you
start that first one the first small
step what terminology do you use
how do we think about it what is better
and worse in the space what are the
principles what are we trying to achieve
and so what a manifesto in the swift
community does is it starts to say
hey well let's step back from the
details of everything let's paint a
broad picture
to talk about how what we're trying to
achieve
let's give an example design point let's
try to
paint the big picture so that then we
can zero in on the individual steps and
make sure that we're making good
progress
and so the swift concurrency manifesto
is something i wrote
three years ago it's been a while maybe
maybe more um
trying to do that for for swift and
concurrency
it starts with some fairly uh simple
things like making the observation that
when you have multiple different
computers or multiple different threads
that are communicating
it's best for them to be asynchronous
right and so you need
things to be able to run separately and
then communicate with each other and
this means asynchrony
and this means that you need a way of
modeling asynchronous communication
many languages have features like this
async await is a
popular one and so that's what i think
is very likely in swift
but as you start building this tower of
abstractions it's not just about
how do you write this you then reach
into the how do you get memory
safety because you want correctness you
want
debuggability and sanity for developers
and how do you get
that memory safety into um into the
language
so if you take a language like go or c
or any of these languages
you get what's called a race condition
when two different threads or go
routines or whatever
touch the same point in memory right
this is a huge like
maddening problem to debug because
it's not reproducible generally and so
there's tools there's a whole ecosystem
of solutions that built up around this
but it's it's a huge problem when you're
writing concurrent code and so
with swift uh this whole value semantics
thing is really powerful there
because it turns out that math and
copies
actually work even in concurrent worlds
and so
you get a lot of safety just out of the
box but there are also some hard
problems and
it talks about some of that when you
start building up to the next level up
and you start talking beyond memory
safety you have to talk about what is
the programmer model
how does a human think about this so a
developer that's trying to build a
program think about this
and it proposes a really old model with
the new spin
called actors actors are about saying we
have
islands of single threadedness logically
so you write something that feels like
it's one programming one program running
in
a unit and then it communicates
asynchronously with other
other things and so
making that expressive and natural feel
good be the first thing you reach for
and being safe by default
is a big part of the design of that
proposal
when you start going beyond that now you
start to say cool well these things that
communicate asynchronously they don't
have to share memory
well if they don't have memory and
they're sending messages to each other
why do they have to be in the same
process
these things should be able to be in
different processes on your machine
and why just processes well why not
different machines
and so now you have a very nice gradual
transition towards distributed
programming
and of course when you start talking
about the big the big future the
the manifesto doesn't go into it but uh
accelerators are
async things you talk to asynchronously
by sending messages to them
and how do you program those well that
that gets very interesting um that's not
that's not in the proposal
so and uh how much
do you want to make that explicit like
the control of that whole process
explicit to the program yeah
good question so when you're designing
any of these kinds of
features or language features or even
libraries you have this really
hard trade-off you have to make which is
how much is it magic or how much is it
in the humans control how much can they
predict and control it
what do you do when the default case is
the wrong case
yeah and so when you're designing a
system um uh
i won't name names but there are systems
where um
you it's really easy to get started
and then you you jump so let's pick like
logo
okay so something like this so it's
really easy to start it's really
designed for
teaching kids but as you get into it you
hit a ceiling
and then you can't go any higher and
then what do you do well you have to go
switch to different world and rewrite
all your code
and this logo is a silly example here
this exists in many other languages
with python you would say like
concurrency right so python has the
global interpreter lock so
threading is challenging in python and
so if you if you start writing a large
scale application in python and then
suddenly you need concurrency
you're kind of stuck with a series of
bad trade-offs right
there's other ways to go where you say
like voiced all the
all the complexity on the user all at
once right
and that's also bad in a different way
and so what what
i what i prefer is building a simple
model that you can explain
that then has an escape hatch so you get
in
you have guardrails you memory safety
works like this in swift where you can
start with you like by default if you
use all the standard things
it's memory safe you're not going to
shoot your foot off but if you want to
get a
a c level pointer to something you can
explicitly do that
but by default it's uh there's rails
there's guardrails okay so but like you
know
uh whose job is it to figure out which
part of the code is paralyzable
um so in the case of the proposal it is
the humans job
so they decide how to architect their
application
and then uh the runtime in the compiler
is very predictable
and so this this is in contrast to um
like there's a long
body of work including on fortran for
auto parallelizing compilers
and um this is an example of a bad thing
in my
so as a compiler person i can write
around compiler people um
often compiler people will say cool
since i can't change the code i'm going
to write my compiler that then takes
this unmodified code
and makes it go way faster on this
machine okay
application develop and so it does
pattern matching it does
like really deep analysis compiler
people are really smart and so they like
wanna
like do something really clever and
tricky and you get like 10x speed
up by taking like an array of structures
and turn it into a structure of arrays
or something because it's so much better
for memory like there's
bodies like tons of tricks yeah um they
love optimization
yeah you love options everyone loves
optimization everybody loves it well and
it's just this promise of build with my
compiler and your thing goes fast
yeah right but here here's the problem
lex you write
you write a program you run it with my
compiler it goes fast you're very happy
wow it's so much faster than the other
compiler
yeah then you go and you add a feature
to your or you refactor some code
and suddenly you got a 10x loss in
performance
well why what just happened there what
just happened there is you
the the heuristic the the the pattern
match in the compiler or whatever
analysis it was doing just got defeated
because
you didn't inline a function or or
something right
as a user you don't know you don't want
to know that the whole point you don't
want to know how the compiler works
you don't want to know how the memory
hierarchy works you don't want to know
how it got parallelized across all these
things
you wanted that abstract away from you
but then the magic is lost as soon as
you did something
and you fall off a performance cliff and
now you're in this funny
position where what do i do i don't
change my code i don't fix that bug
it costs 10x performance now what do i
do well this is the problem with
unpredictable performance right if if
you care about performance
predictability is a very important thing
and so um and so what the what the
proposal does is it provides a
architectural patterns for being able to
layout your code gives you full control
over that
makes it really simple so you can
explain it and then
and then if you want to scale out in
different ways you have full control
over that
so in your sense the intuition is for a
compiler it's too hard to do
automated parallelization like you know
because the compilers do
stuff automatically that's incredibly
impressive for other things
right but for parallelization we're not
even
we're not close to there well it depends
on the programming model so compil
there's many different kinds of
compilers
and so if you talk about like a c
compiler or a swift compiler or
something like that where
you're writing imperative code
parallelizing that and reasoning about
all the pointers and stuff like that is
very is a very difficult problem
now if you switch domains so there's
this cool thing called machine learning
right so machine the machine learning
nerds among other endearing things like
you know solving
cat detectors and other things like that
um
have done this amazing breakthrough of
producing a programming model
operations that you compose together
that has raised the level of abstraction
high enough
that suddenly you can have auto
parallelizing compilers
you can write a model using uh
tensorflow and have it run on
1024 nodes of a tpu yeah
i didn't even think about like you know
because there's so much flexibility in
the design of architectures that
ultimately boil down to a graph that's
paralyzable for you paralyzed for you
and and if you think about it that's
pretty cool that's pretty right
yeah and you think about batching for
example as a way of being able to
exploit more parallelism
yeah like that's a very simple thing
that now is very powerful
that didn't come out of the programming
language nerds right those people
like that came out of people that are
just looking to solve a problem and use
a few gpus and
organically developed by the community
of people focusing on machine learning
as an incredibly powerful powerful
abstraction layer
that enables the compiler people to go
and exploit that and
now you can drive supercomputers from
python
you